welcome in the safety blitz starting the
two-time super bowl champion rodney
harrison jack collinsworth we got to
start with sunday night football the
washington football team the
philadelphia eagles that we just
witnessed what tanking looks like in the
nfl what were your thoughts rodney as
that fourth quarter played out last
night
i was sick i was sick i couldn't believe
first and foremost that he took jalen um
hurts out and i was so disappointed i
said you're putting in the third string
quarterback and you haven't even really
seen enough from your second from your
second stream quarterback who's your
first string quarterback i was really
disappointed but i got to tell you this
i lost a lot of respect for doug
peterson because as a former player
he would absolutely never quit
and and you mean to tell me now that
you're a head coach you're quitting
i mean it's
you talk about a fractured relationship
between him
and carson wentz what about a fractured
relationship between him and jalen hurts
jalen hurts is a dog and he wants to do
whatever he can to win a football game
and you as the head coach offensive
coordinator
you basically
pull him out and you freaking lose the
game you just purposely lose the game
and if i'm jalen hurts i don't know how
i look at doug peterson and and respect
him as a man respect him as a coach how
can i i just couldn't i couldn't respect
him jack i just couldn't respect him man
i was i was disappointed as a former
player
i was mad i was angry and then i was sad
and i'm like
why won't they play let these guys play
i was just really disappointed jack
sorry
i think all of that's very fair so after
sudden fell through the first
interception it was an ugly pick i mean
he just lofted it up it was kind of a
punt pick where you just throw it up and
it's pretty obvious from the second it
left his hand it was going to be
intercepted you knew he was clear and
obviously a backup quarterback at best
that's that's just what he is that's
what he's been his old career it's what
he was when you put him in for that
first drive it's the fourth quarter of a
game that you have every chance to go
win
when i first got ticked off is when they
put him back in the game when they put
it back in that second drive the eagles
defense figures out a way to get an
interception force a turnover give you a
chance to go win the thing and then you
go back to sunfield that is when i said
doug peterson one of the great fourth
quarter coaches that upset the patriots
in the super bowl with nick foles when
he had no
you know no chance to go do so being so
aggressive in all the things that he did
in that game
for him to coach this fourth quarter
this way
i'm not willing to say that he was
totally going to lose it but he made
every tactical decision every tactical
move to make sure they didn't win this
game and i don't know why i don't know
if you just said ron rivera and alex
smith with everything they've been
through i prefer them going to the
playoffs over the giants maybe that was
his decision or maybe he just decided
that he wanted to move up three picks in
the draft for me either one is not
suffice especially not in prime time
maybe 1 pm sunday you get away with this
in week 17 and prime time this is
something that won't go away in my
opinion
and he sits there
and the thing that makes it even worse
he sits there and he plays us as fans as
football guys that study this stuff
every single day of our lives
and he plays us like we're complete
idiots and he's and he's sitting there
looking us in in our eyes and saying
that
i'm trying to do everything i can to win
this football game he's lying like how
could you over like repeatedly lie to
your players lie to your staff you're
lying to us as fans like i'm just
maybe it's an organizational thing and
maybe they said hey doug you you we're
going to take care of you make sure that
you're
you're still here making your salary
you're going to be the head coach but
you take the blame for this because i
can't see
a general manager a owner allowing this
to happen
you know yeah i understand that it's the
ninth pick compared to the sixth pick
but we're talking about college kids
that never even played one single down
in national football league jack so how
do we know
how good this player is gonna be you're
going to lose a game in the nfl based
off of trying to go get a college guy
i just don't get it and and and i just
feel i'm angry at doug peterson
when i look at him i know he's lying
it's 100
he's lying and if i feel this way
imagine those guys that look at him
every single day all those guys that
look at him every single day
and say you know what we can't even
trust our coach we can't even trust our
coach because he can't even tell us the
truth it's a shame
you've been around this game forever
you're not believing what you're hearing
the whole city of philadelphia is not
believing what they're hearing i'll
never forget jalen hurts on the
sidelines shaking his head there's a
clip it's just the camera shot's so you
know closed tight on his mouth and you
see him go this is just not right this
is just not right so hertz is not
believing what he's hearing either let's
hear from coach he's had a night to
sleep on it now so here was doug
peterson today gathering his thoughts on
what played out last night
i was coaching and win to win
yes that was my decision solely
nate has obviously been here for
four years
and
i felt that uh he he deserved an
opportunity to uh to get some to get
some snaps and um
um
listen uh if if there's anything out
there that that thinks that i was
not trying to win the game i mean you
know
ertz is out there brandon graham's out
there darius slays out there
you know all our top guys are still on
the field at the end so
uh we were we were going to win the game
my question to you then is
why would you do that is this just for
the draft picks or
is this something else that we're
missing here
pretty simple um i wanted to get the
plan this week was to get nate some time
and
i felt like it was the time to get him
in the game
doug now that you've had a night to
sleep on it um
i know you're a guy that
respects the game very much and
last night when you took out jalen uh in
a close game i think you're aware that
it sent a message kind of across the
league i think fan eagles fans were
upset about it but i think football fans
were upset about what it said um
can you speak to that now that you've
slept on it a little bit about um
you know the message that may be that
that sent and the perception that people
had about
the way that the game panned out
you know i i've thought about that quite
a bit and um uh you know quite frankly i
look at the entire body of work i look
at the entire season and it's definitely
not the season that we all had
anticipated and
you know our our offensive
struggles have have not been about you
know one one position group or or one
guy or
you know uh
whatever it's it's it's it's been a it's
been a a multi multitude of of issues
that we've had and
and and again last night in that game
you know we were in a situation where we
we failed to score as an offense we
failed to score there at the end of the
third quarter we were struggling just a
little bit to move the ball
defensively they kept us
kept us in the game with a couple of
takeaways late and and and my plan was
to was to get nate in the game nate
nate's nate's a guy that that is very
capable of of running our system and
executing in in
an opportunity to to to pull that game
out last night and
come on now nate sud phil is garbage
he's been there four years he hasn't
played and you wait to the as much as
carson wentz has struggled throughout
the year then you decide you had an
opportunity to go to nate
when carson wentz was struggling but
then you decide to give jalen hurts an
opportunity he plays well and then all
of a sudden the last game of the year
and it's a difference between a draft
pick picking you know number nine and
number six you decide to play them come
on doug come on come on peterson like
that that is such a bunch of garbage and
you sit here and talk to us like we're
idiots like we're just flat out idiots i
mean your dad played for a long time you
grew up in football your whole life was
about football
same here with me i've been playing
football since i was six years old we
all watch tape we share information and
we sit and look at both of these guys
and you can tell they're lying
i'm just i'm just sick man doug peterson
i mean just saying what he said a day
after
like are you kidding me come on doug
stop with the bs
this is a franchise that's showing every
sign of moving on from their 100 million
dollar quarterback and carson wentz
they're showing every sign of that and
they're transitioning this thing to
hertz and was hurts perfect to start
that game no he wasn't but it was clear
and obvious that his legs gave this
offense an element that you weren't
going to get from sutfield he had two
rushing touchdowns already in that game
and as you're going to sit down on
tuesday and evaluate the long-term
prospects of your quarterback room
you needed that fourth quarter
evaluation of jalen hurts to make a wise
decision about which direction your
entire franchise is headed you needed
that fourth quarter so even bigger than
moving up three slots i felt like you
hadn't seen enough on hurts yet there's
just no way that the back half of the
season when they really fell out of the
playoff push was enough to get a full
and clear evaluation on hertz and while
he had struggled you're going is he
going to bounce back and finish this
game and go get a win and knock
washington out of the playoffs and to be
honest with you even though they were
down and they hadn't got that fourth
down play that you referenced right
before we came on rodney it still felt
like hurts had a chance to go win this
game there's just something about the
momentum and the feel and the everything
and to me nobody rides and feels the
momentum of a game quite like doug
peterson so for him to make that move
and then double down on it and triple
down on it again and just keep putting
sunfeld back in the game
you just left going this is the most
peculiar football game i've ever watched
it's the worst coached fourth quarter
i've ever seen
and in all likelihood it's probably you
know
most clearly the first time i've ever
thought that's what tanking looks like
in the nfl that's what it is
quarterback is the most valuable
position that's it's the most valuable
position if you're going to put somebody
out there that you know stinks these are
the results you know you're going to get
and that's the results they got
and my my question to you is this if
you're if you're a free agent
and
philadelphia has interest in you
would you think twice about going
and sign him with the philadelphia
eagles
i don't i don't know that this one thing
would be enough if i'm being completely
and totally honest with you i don't know
that this one move would be enough but
man did to say a lot to me about how
confident doug peterson is that he's
going to keep his job this sort of felt
like a game he needed to win like he
needed to go out just get some momentum
bump into the off-season and if you're
willing to just completely throw this
for the benefit of draft picks
says a lot about his confidence that
he's going to be the head coach of the
future doesn't it would you would this
be enough to deter you from being an
eagle
if if i'm a free agent and i saw what
doug peterson did think about it because
i still think like a football player i'm
48 years old but i still feel like i'm
right there in the mix there's no way i
don't care how much they paid me i
wouldn't go i would go somewhere else be
because i'm a man of principle okay it's
not just about the dollars and cents and
if i can't look my coach in the eye and
respect him i don't want to play for him
and i played for the greatest the
greatest ever do it coach belichick and
every day i could look at him in his
eyes because i knew he was being honest
i knew that he was telling me the truth
i knew that i could trust him and with
doug peterson i just can't say that i i
cannot say that
as bad as it was on the philadelphia
side and it's about as bad of an ending
of the season as i can remember it was
equally as incredible for the washington
football team for coach rivera battling
through cancer all season long and
figuring out a way to get this team into
the playoffs for alex smith who was sent
packing by san francisco sent packing by
kansas city finds his way to washington
has one of the most gruesome injuries
that you've ever seen in nfl history
comes back he's like just really to
prove to his kids that he could do it
that never quit mentality gets back on
the field and then takes this team
somehow to the playoffs we got to hear
from the victors here we're coach and
quarterback after an incredible run to
get this team into the playoffs
all i care about this is division champs
uh
still alive um
you know and that that was
every off season when you get together
as a team the number one goal the the
easiest way to get a ticket to the dance
is win the division and uh
you know it certainly wasn't looking
likely there for a long time the
beginning of the year for us and and uh
to be here now though like i said i
think says a lot about the character we
got don't judge us from where we've been
judge us for where we're going so let's
see how we handle this going forward
you know this is a big opportunity for
us
um you know i love what they said about
just getting in and and that's all we
needed was a chance to get in we'll see
what happens we're going to play against
a very good football team with uh you
know uh
a lot of good football players and so
i'm excited about it
yeah jack you look at both those guys
they're so inspirational everything that
they've gone through they don't complain
they don't expect anyone to feel sorry
for them i look at alex smith and i went
through a gruesome knee injury um i i
tore three of four three out of four of
my ligaments and i had an issue in a
hospital where
i found out that you know there was a
possibility that my leg could be
actually amputated and i was going
through a lot of pain i had the swelling
was really bad the knee was the whole
leg was like black it was a very scary
thing so when those players look at alex
smith and they see the type of rehab he
went through with the type of attitude
the positive attitude that he has
going through it they're inspired and
they'll do anything for alex smith and i
think when you look at your head
coaching he's battling cancer and he's
humble because ron rivera is a very
humble strong man and you see alex smith
no matter how you feel during the day
you look at those two guys and you look
and see what they had to go through it
motivates you and it pumps you up
because they don't take anything for
granted they work their tails off to be
where they're at and they stay positive
with a great attitude and i think that's
a big reason why
the washington football team has had
success this year is ron rivera and his
guidance
rodney how much different are those
thoughts are those conversations with
your family members with your coaches
with anybody who maybe have an influence
in your life when it is not only a
football injury something that could end
your career but something that could be
life-altering that you may not be able
to play with your kids the same you may
not be able to just walk down the street
the same how much different is that
conversation when you were going through
it
it's tough man it's a tough conversation
you know but you look at your wife and
you you have a conversation with her and
you guys try to figure out what's best
and um it was a point in time the
following year in 2008 i think well in
2008
i tore my knee up and i looked at my
wife and i just i just said you know
what i'm done i'm done i can't go
through this anymore because you look at
your family members you look at your
your kids and wanting to be able to go
and play catch with them and work out
with them and go to their football games
without walking with the limp or being
pushed in a wheelchair you weigh all
those different things so i i just look
at alex smith and everything
and people don't understand like how
significant this injury was like this
dude could have lost his leg and think
about you know the compromises he would
have had to make with his children so
i'm just really happy that he's at a
point now
um where he can play he's healthy he's
positive and i think he's going to play
a lot better because you look at and i'm
just going to go football wise you look
at tampa tampa does a lot of blitzing
so but alex is really good with taking
care of the football although he you
know had a couple interceptions last
week a lot of quick pass get the ball
out of his hands quickly so he can have
success against this defense it's not
like you know alex smith is a bomb alex
smith has a lot of experience and and
obviously he's not afraid
the thing that's amazing to me is
watching him still be able to have this
success just to be able to put together
this playoff run win the games they had
to
when he used to be a mobile quarterback
he used to be somebody who could pull
down and just go run for a handful of
first downs per game run and create you
know more opportunities with his arm and
that's really eliminated from his game
even really driving off of that back
foot to put some extra sauce into a
throw has kind of left his game a little
bit he's dealing with the calf injury
also so to see him evolve it's almost
like like a jump shooter or something
when they have no speed left no ability
to get to the basket they can only shoot
threes he's just had to change totally
change what makes his game successful
and still be able to succeed so that to
me is amazing to watch now they didn't
score a ton of points against philly and
philly is a bad defense and so if you
can't score a ton of points against
philly is there reason to believe rodney
in your mind's eye that they will be
able to score against tampa because you
know brady this buck's offense they have
never been hotter and they may be one of
the hottest offenses in the entire
league as it currently sits
well they do have antonio gibson so the
run game you know has to be present
terry mclaren hopefully he can play
logan thomas the big tight end so they
have weapons on offensive side and
remember alex smith he missed some time
so when he came back that was almost
like a um
you know like a touch-up game that's you
know and he turned the ball over a
couple times i guarantee you against
tampa he's going to take care of the
football they're going to run the
football and he'll play a lot
a lot better with with uh actually with
a lot more confidence so i'm looking
forward to seeing alex smith and what
he's capable of doing um but when you
look at tampa bay
mike evans the loss of mike evans is
huge i mean to have a receiver six five
two thirty that can you could just throw
the ball up and tom and trust me i know
tom brady i know tom brady and tom is
sick right now yeah antonio brown's
doing great but it's nothing like having
a 6'5 wide receiver that you can throw
the ball basically anywhere in his
vicinity and he can go up and get it i
think that's a huge loss for tampa bay
it is a huge loss it's a huge loss in
the size department especially and we'll
transition it right now to tampa bay and
to this offense and we had kind of been
waiting on antonio brown to really make
his mark and it had felt like for a
handful of weeks there that he was
getting ready for an explosion we've now
seen sort of back to back explosions for
him and i always like to look at the how
his touchdowns came how his big moments
came in that game and both of them were
tom brady getting himself into trouble
scrambling around a little bit and the
first one a b broke so hard to the pile
on to the side piling in the end zone
the safety just fell down he was trying
to cover him he just fell down and the
second touchdown was kind of the exact
same thing he ran a mesh route he's lost
in the in the pile in the middle of the
field brady's in trouble and he breaks
right to the sideline he finds him and
he's too fast he turns the corner and
goes and scores and so that to me points
to a chemistry that's starting to form
between these two because remember it's
not their first year playing together
they at least got to build a little bit
of that in new england i really think
we're seeing come to fruition now in
tampa
what would have eventually came to
fruition in new england and you better
be careful with tampa bay because this
is still the greatest quarterback of all
time the most experienced playoff
quarterback of all time and this is in
my opinion the most weaponry the best
players that have surrounded him ever
and one of the best defenses that he's
out around him too i think this team is
being slept on in a big way and you may
see them go make some serious damage
come late playoff time late january and
into early february and that'd be a
super bowl home game for them too rod
you just hit it jack you said january
and tom brady in january
nobody does it better than him you know
tom is a very competitive guy and we
talk we haven't even talked about ronald
jones being back and you look at you
look at antonio brown
when you watch him on tape i want you to
go back and watch that game if you can
and watch how fast he looks he looks
like he's getting his legs up under him
he's in shape he's you know and he's
going to get more opportunities because
of um
the kid that got hurt i'm sorry
mike evans yeah because mike evans got
hurt now i don't know if mike evans is
going to play this weekend or not
but he's definitely going to get more
opportunities and he looks really really
good now you see him on these these um
jet sweeps and tom is tossing him the
ball and he's throwing the ball down the
field and he's going in these short
intermediate routes so the entire
playbook is open for antonio brown and
you see that he's playing with a lot of
energy and excitement he's and he's
bringing it man
yeah evan's day-to-day right now for
chris godwin it's starting to feel like
that there's that trust forming there
too it's like everybody's talked about
new england the triangle of trust for
tom brady i feel like we're starting to
see the new triangle of trust down there
in tampa and while gronk can't quite run
like he used to he still demands the
same kind of respect you still see
coverage move to gronk so he's still
having the same effect on a game scotty
miller is somebody that tom brady has
loved all year you're seeing him slowly
work back into this offense so maybe
it's not a triangle of trust anymore
this may be more like a i don't even
know like he's got four or five guys
that he trusts going into january and
that's going to be an interesting thing
to see and no egos too rodney it's like
how how can antonio brown and chris
godwin and gronk and all these guys mike
evans scottie miller how can all of
these guys be having the kind of years
that they are getting hot right now and
you don't hear anything about any egos
there's one answer and it's tom brady
absolutely what
that's why you're my man right there tom
brady and you knew tom with his
leadership he was gonna preach
unselfishness he was gonna come in there
and he was going to push those guys he
was going to be in a weight room by 5
a.m getting those guys working out being
together practicing going over tape
that's what tom brady brings and that's
why he was so precious and he was so
respected not just because he won super
bowls but it was the process and and we
saw we got a chance to see tom brady
work i walk in the weight room 5 30 and
six o'clock in the morning he's up in
there
full sweat what's up you late rodney
you're an hour late what's up why are
you late you know then i come in the
next day it's 5 30 in the morning oh
still late hunt rodney still late and
then i walked up to him and said hey man
i'm not like you i can't get up this
road i'm not coming to weight room 5
o'clock so leave me alone but that's
that's just tom tom's personality he he
does such a wonderful job of trying to
bring people together and just um you
know just win he's just such a
competitive guy he asked me at the
beginning of this year he says hey man
do you believe in me and i was like yeah
and
i didn't know what to really say but
yeah i said yeah i believe in you and he
said well we're gonna get it you know
but that's tom brady the confidence that
he brings and you you see it i mean
that's the confidence that he exudes and
everyone's feeling it
and i have a whole new respect through
his mentorship too of antonio brown a
guy who had all kinds of struggles for
him to just put his arm around him say
come live in my house anything you need
antonio just kind of coach him up mentor
him up throughout the course of this
year and then go get him as 250k
to finish it out just three little touch
passes at the end of that game to make
sure that's what i was talking about 250
000 incentive that is what great friends
do and that's what's happening right now
in tampa bay it's why they're on such a
heater in the season speaking of heaters
let's get to some running backs we've
covered the aerial attack let's get to
the ground game derek henry something we
talked a lot about he had to go 250 plus
in order to go get this 2 000
yard mark on the season give us some
context on what derek henry has done
this year how hard is that
brother let me tell you something it's
amazing
for him a guy like that to get 2 000
yards 250 yards in the last game
typically in the last game you're tired
you're worn down and he looked fresh he
looked fresh like it was just the first
month of the season but it's very
difficult to get 2 000 yards that's why
not many guys get 2 000 yards they don't
have teams don't have the patience with
these quarterbacks throwing the ball all
over the field and they won't commit to
the football the run game but the thing
that no one's talking about with derek
henry and the tennessee titans is that
offensive line that they lost jack
conklin taylor lawn to free agency
taylor lawan got hurt and they lost him
he's an all-pro tackle he's an all-pro
tackle when they lose him and they just
keep going on 2 000 yards it's just
amazing but i got to give that offensive
line a lot of credit because they've
been terrific
you have to and i bet if you ask every
single one of those offensive linemen
they would tell you how much they love
blocking for derrick henry because they
did they completely controlled that line
of scrimmage yesterday but when derek
henry gets into the linebackers and gets
into the secondary he is one of the
great nightmares for any db to try to
make a play on and that's why you see so
many of these runs that would be 10 or
12 or 15 yard runs become 60 or become
80 or become 90 yard touchdown runs
because he gets there and not only is he
bigger than them more powerful than them
stronger than them he shocks him with
his speed he just shocks him with his
speed and they try to take an angle on
him and they try to go get him thinking
he's going to be a power running back
and he's not just a power running back
and if you take even this much of a
wrong angle you're going to meet that
stiff arm from the heavens of which i
know a lot about and so he has all of
these great tools that he works in and
he's a marathon runner too he played
every game this year 16 games 13 of
those games he went over 20 carries that
is how you go get 2 000 yards he's a
workhorse a marathon runner and a heck
of a sprinter too
yeah and i'll tell you this from a
defensive standpoint if i saw derek
henry coming at me i would go and just
go right at his knees and we have a term
a phrase that we use chop the tree down
okay i don't care how big the tree is i
don't care how big the guy is if you hit
him in his knee and he's we we always
say
big guys have skinny knees because you
you know what i'm saying they have
skinny knees and and no one wants to be
hitting their knee so the problem with a
lot of defenders they go high and this
guy benches 400 pounds so all he's gonna
do is throw you away but if you go at
his knees and you wrap them and you hold
on for dear life and you twist and you
turn and wait for your calvary to come
you're gonna get him down and trust me
derek henry is six three two fifty he
doesn't want anybody coming at his knees
stop trying to tackle him high he's too
big he's too strong and that's one way
you talked about the speed and i think a
lot of guys really underestimated speed
i think you were spot on with that but
the other thing is chop the tree down
and you got to go at his knees
that's a great point and there was a
moment in that game yesterday where jj
watt had just an arm attack you know
he's always chasing it from the backside
jj has the speed to come from the
backside if you don't get a handle he'll
make that play in the backfield and he
was perfectly in position to do so
yesterday and he put an arm around derek
henry and i'll never forget the sight of
derek
acting like he wasn't even there it was
almost like he didn't even touch him and
j.j watt just falls kind of gets slung
onto the ground that is the derrick
henry difference is that those little
arm tackles are not enough to get him on
the ground and so you put the
combination of everything you can do and
it's just a scary scary sight we had
another running back go over 250 though
indianapolis jonathan taylor went off as
well whose maybe performance was more
impressive what do you think about what
indy's putting together as we enter the
playoff push
well i love what frank wright is doing
when he runs the football
he has to run the football and when he
runs the football they have success you
know take the ball out of philip rivers
hands and allow this guy he is big he's
thick he's 220 plus pounds he runs at
4-3 and it just seems like
the pro game for whatever reason
is is more you know
accommodating to his game to his style
of play i think he's been terrific this
year he's given him that solid
foundation nahim hines is a great
compliment to him you see ty hilton but
jonathan taylor is the key and that's
frank wright you have to run the ball
giving the ball 25 30 times that's the
way you're gonna have a chance against
the buffalo bills
and the only player that graded higher
than jonathan taylor yesterday was one
quentin nelson and probably rightfully
so he's in there moving mountains one of
my favorite things too about big q is
you know he'll break this bit i mean
there's so many runs if you watched that
indianapolis game yesterday where
jonathan taylor's 15 20 yards down the
field without being touched yet and my
favorite part is to watch quentin nelson
who hits a perfect block and he
immediately starts sprinting down the
field just at full speed that goes back
to the notre dame games where he would
say i want to be first to the party man
and there's nobody that parties like
quentin nelson i can promise you that
okay let's get it to uh buffalo bills
the bills are smoking down the home
stretch my question for you is very
simple rodney harrison
are they the single biggest contender as
you look around the nfl to kansas city
based on the way that they play football
and what this offense can do
absolutely i mean i i look at the
offense and even more so than offense
collectively as a team
they're young and this team is hungry
they want it they play for one another
they love each
other
they love josh allen and josh allen is
such a young
such a really good young leader and it's
genuine it's not phony when you watch
him lead you don't say oh this is a
phony guy his teammates sincerely love
they're this guy and i'm tell you
and i like the bills not just because of
their offense we know they can put up
points but because of their defense
their defense is better compared to the
first time they met the safeties are are
really good i think their secondary is
legit um i like what the bills are doing
leslie frazier defensive coordinator
he's done a wonderful job he's a lot
more aggressive he's blitz and these
guys are flying around they're playing
with a lot of confidence and um yeah i
would say
definitely the buffalo bills is probably
the biggest threat to kansas city
i think they are right now too they've
been a top five scoring defense since
week 12 like you're saying so they've
just been getting better down the home
stretch through the december stretch of
this season and kansas city really has
been going the opposite direction over
that same period of time ever since that
denver game on sunday night football
where everybody really thought that
kansas city would just blow denver out
vic fangio had different plans we
haven't seen that kansas city offense
get back to dominating form yet and for
the bills it's been the opposite i mean
if josh allen had put together this
stretch the entire season he probably
would have been the mvp he's probably
the mvp of the second half of the year
if not for maybe aaron rodgers who's
been damn near perfect too uh but you
look at you look at this bill let me let
me hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on
hold on yeah go ahead rodney jack yeah
you look at kansas city and
and i've been in this situation where
you win a super bowl and you give
everything to win that super bowl and
then all of a sudden yep you know
they're dealing with a pandemic they're
dealing with the fact that they can't
spend time and just like everybody else
and they still they're still 14 and two
and people are complaining do you
understand like how much energy these
guys are tired and that's one of the
reasons why andy reid rested his guys
he's got a break but he rested them a
week before the break why because
they're tired all the all the media
obligations just all the time all the
pounding getting the very best from
every single team that you're playing
these guys are tired but i guarantee you
in the playoffs they're going to come
out firing because they're going to be
rested mentally physically and they're
going to sit back and say you know what
we're hungry again a lot of times when
you're in the mix and you know you're
really good sometimes you get bored with
beating some of these teams but they've
gone on the road they beat good teams
they beat good teams at home i don't
know what everybody else wants it's hard
trying to defend back-to-back
championships it's hard trying to win
that second championship because you
know everybody has studied you in the
off-season everybody
they went out and drafted because of you
a certain way defensive backs defensive
ends and i just think that you know
i think kansas city is going to be okay
don't worry about kansas city i do
believe that clyde edwards hilaire
that's a huge loss and i do believe that
it's a major drop-off from le'veon bell
to him i just i i thought that soon as
soon as they signed le'veon bell i said
it's a it's a major drop-off i'm like i
would rather see le'veon bell i don't
want to see cloud edwards hilaire
because he's tough he's young he's
hungry he's physical and he's tough to
find in the back in you know in a
and uh in the backfields excuse me
of course of course i i've always
thought that being smaller is an
advantage in football people like to
talk about it like it's a disadvantage
it's a leverage game man best defensive
player in the world is aaron donald for
about five years running now one of the
smaller defensive linemen you'll find
but when you're talking about this
bill's team if it wasn't for that fail
murray you know the hail murray in week
10 this would have been 10 straight that
they've won coming down the home stretch
but ever since that week 10 game i mean
nobody's coming with the possession as
they've gone on this six game win streak
with buffalo nobody's even come within a
possession of them so not only is the
defense playing great the offense is
extending these leads and i also like
the sean mcdermott strategy of i don't
want to arrest anybody i want us going
into the playoffs with a tailwind let's
ride this momentum wave that we've been
on why the heck would i go arrest
everybody and risk us getting out of
this thing and brian davil is offensive
coordinator since 2018 you got to think
about how many times young quarterbacks
just go through one offensive
coordinator after another offensive
quarter maybe a new head coach comes in
it's a constant change of scenery for
young quarterbacks because they're in
these struggling franchises and i think
the ability to keep not only head coach
but offensive coordinator and brian
dable in place has been such a huge key
and when you talk to josh allen he'll
tell you that has led to some of this
comfort because he's now winning on time
and he's also winning off schedule which
is all the god-given ability that he has
yeah i know brian dabal has been
considered for head coaching jobs but
sometimes it's best to sit where you're
at as a coordinator but i know if he
gets an opportunity he has to take it
but he's a good guy he was with me in
new england he's a very smart guy and
he's done a wonderful job with josh
allen really proud of both those guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports